ethan Behrman is a radio host in
california he joins us tonight so Ethan
are you comfortable with that standard
and I know the standard reply it's not a
legal proceeding but fairness applies in
all proceedings especially when there's
a lot at stake like a man's job in
reputation like what his children think
of him and are you comfortable with the
standard that once accused of something
that you should be the one who disproves
the accusation that it's up to you to
prove what they're saying about she
wasn't true are you okay with that I
think what we have to have is a hearing
of both sides so we're gonna have that
at least from dr. Ford we need to hear
from all of the accusers we also most
importantly need to hear under oath from
the actual wit suppose it witnesses to
the events that occurred this is not by
the way I think it's really important
though to go back to something that you
just point out it is not a criminal
trial due process does not apply the
same way this is like a job application
oh no hold on hold on let me just back
up you're arguing something parallel to
what I asked you I am in favor of
hearing all the evidence we had have
access to including when and where the
supposed crime took place which is a
very basic question still unanswered but
the question is what do you make of your
party leaders members of the Judiciary
Committee saying that the onus is on the
accused to prove he's not guilty this is
not something we're taking out of
context we have at least three
Democratic members of the Judiciary
Committee saying that in plain English
it's up to him prove you're not guilty
are you comfortable with that standard
that's an unamerican standard we've
never seen it before ever in American
history it's happening now and I want to
know what you think of it I'm not
comfortable with the scenario see we
have to say prove you're not guilty but
here's the difference when there's a
single I've been consistent about this
throughout the entire me tube movement
when there's a single accuser it's hard
for me to call for somebody's job to be
lost once we have multiple credible
accusers come forward which we have in
this case plus Michael avenatti is
teasing a third one out there right now
now we have a pattern and yes now we
need to look very deeply into this and
we should you put things but does it it
could does it occur to you that we have
a pattern of people making charges they
can't substantiate to achieve political
ends is that a possible explanation for
this would that be am i a sexist for
suggesting it
look we have two really big issues one I
I don't like that politics is the
bloodsport that it is today the
Democrats sat on the letter for seven
weeks you and I can actually agree on
something I didn't like that either but
politics is politics so they sat on it
to try and delay this but what has
happened now is we have women who are
being slammed and slandered and attacked
and disbelieved and we are in the middle
of the meeting moment after a thousand
yes successful in their abuse give them
their junuh
it's not about all men and it's not
about all women it's about one man and
one woman it's not about me it's not
about you it's Brett Kavanaugh and
Christine Ford it's a very the case is
specific we're not putting men on trial
or trying to exonerate women for the
crimes committed by our ancestors we're
talking about the here and now in this
in the Senate Judiciary Committee let me
ask you a very specific question about
Christine Ford and you're suggesting
that you're not allowed to disbelieve
somebody but I retain my right of reason
and I can determine as an adult in a US
citizen whether I believe the evidence
or not and until they come from him and
to do that but let me ask you this does
she have responsibility she's claiming
that this man sexually assaulted her and
altered the course of her life she can't
fly in airplanes it's affects a
relationship with men he's a predator
she didn't tell anybody his name for 36
years during which time he got married
he interacted with many others in our
population sex offenders tend to commit
serial sex crimes doesn't she have an
obligation to tell someone to stop him
from doing that if he is in fact a sex
criminal where's your obligation here
that's the rest of it okay
no because every psychologist will tell
you there are eight primary reasons why
a sexual assault victim why a trauma
victim doesn't come forward doesn't talk
I'm asking her about her reasons I'm
sure just a million reasons and maybe
they're legitimate I'm asking about the
rest of us the other the other 320
million people who live here if he's
actually a sex criminal we have a right
to know that and she has an obligation
to tell us and I know it's hard but why
don't we have a right to know if there's
a rapist on the loose if you don't tell
anybody if Bernie Madoff rips you off
and you don't tell his others investors
you're you're part of the problem are
you not or what am I missing
well duck doc dr. Ford did communicate
with her therapist she has she's
produced that evidence she's gonna do
honey in front of the committee which is
but why not just tell that she didn't
name him for 36 years I'm not saying
it's not true I'm saying if it is true
what's going on here don't the rest of
us have a right to protect ourselves
from this dangerous man right know what
I mean I what what yes yeah yeah hang on
hang on so you have a very powerful
person here a judge on the 9th Circuit
of the United States of America he's
been dating I mean you were just Tucker
you were just talking about the
privileged elite and the wealthy and
those in power that is Brett Kavanaugh
from day one he went to an elite
boarding school on the East Coast went
straight into Yale he is the most elite
of the elite you're intentionally
dodging my question which is about car
service ability you know I'm serious to
protect the rest of us if this is true
I'm taking her at face value and I think
it's not just about her and her feelings
there's a responsibility to others
around you in the society at large which
we're ignoring on purpose because we're
all terrified to say anything that's
true because we think we're gonna be
punished for doing that and you know
that's true let me ask you really
quickly about gritty porn about creepy
porn lawyer here so all of a sudden this
guy who was the lawyer for stormy
Daniels jumps up and down and makes a
spectacle of himself and the press kind
of a bets that and it's sort of a joke
but now he's back and the press is
making him even bigger here's this
election Michael a Vinod is a beast okay
that's true and he's a beast he's a
beast Jon Meacham says he may be the
savior of the Republic that's a great
bigger calling hear that being a lawyer
is minimal compared to what he's doing
the priesthood would whatever he's out
there saving the country Oh Michael
avenatti an apology for the last couple
of weeks I've been saying I'm not for
reading Michael I've seen you everywhere
what do you love to say I was wrong
brother you have a lot to say the
Democrats could learn something for you
all right so they're promoting him from
the very start and that was fine when he
was doing a creepy porn stuff was kind
of hilarious we played along alright but
the press is now starting to fall for
its own joke they're taking creepy porn
lawyers seriously and allowing him to
make the Supreme Court nomination of
Brett Kavanaugh all about himself here's
from today
it's not about one specific allegations
it's a series of allegations this is a
pattern of behavior Rachel that took
place across many months and many years
I believe that when these allegations
are surfaced within the next 48 hours
there will be no question that Brett
Kavanaugh is not fit to sit on the US
Supreme Court
he hasn't provided the allegations
needless to say this guy's a buffoon
Ethan these are serious charges
presumably coming from serious people
the consequences are serious why let
this charlatan intrude on the process
why are Democrats allowing this guy to
take center stage well Michael avenatti
is taking a page out of Trump's own
playbook manipulating the media to his
own benefit but here's the difference
Michael avenatti has actually brought
the goods since he started representing
mrs. Clifford stormy Daniels he's
actually brought the goods when he's
made these allegations now he's saying
but Nolan but in this specific case he's
suggesting he's got nothing to do with
any of this obviously he's trying to
stay famous and he's saying the Brett
Kavanaugh was part of a rape ring he's
not gonna get sued for center he should
he's not did Democrats really want to be
tied to someone that reckless honestly
well I don't know anything about the
allegation about a rape ring but he
claims to have a very well vetted out a
reliable another accuser and I'm very
interested he's teasing it out over 48
hours so that time hasn't quite come yet
and I'm curious to see what he's gonna
bring because again he's brought the
goods since he started representing
stormy Daniels he's well he's certainly
I've made some money as stormy Daniels
is still getting beer bottles thrown at
her on stage and strip bars in Richmond
but I don't know is does he really know
a lot guess we'll see and maybe you know
he's your he's your presidential
candidate so I guess we'll find out I'm
for Garcetti I'm for Garcetti good man
Ethan great to see you thanks